Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Vincent,
where are you going to be Jane?
Well,
this week Colusa casino.
February 23rd one night.
Only one show on way and uh,
and then,
uh,
March 30th and 31st hearing them comedy club in Portland.
Tickets are moving really fast.
So if you guys want to go get those tickets and now Bros and then I'm adding
some other stuff,
I'll be announcing it very soon.
Music's really loud and is screaming.
Sorry about that.
Gosh.
You know,
especially with those new bell tones.
You guys.
Okay,
thanks.
Really clicking there.
Okie doke.
Um,
I'll be in Lexington,
Kentucky,
Kentucky.
Yeah,
I like that one.
It's all sold out.
Columbus,
Ohio.
So Salt Lake [inaudible] even announce it gets her gone.
So here's the thing.
Uh,
I'm going to be in Spokane.
Sperm can Washington,
may 17 through 19,
Charlotte,
North Carolina at the end of May and into June.
Mama how Nebraska Braya California
and breast falls,
beach,
Florida.
Those are all@timesgo.com slash tour.
Um,
technically
I'm not supposed to.
I can't get into the details of it,
but I will tell you that there is going to be a change in my schedule.
Can,
oh my God,
I can't say anything yet because it's not an official,
I wouldn't say anything,
but I'm saying don't get mad at me when this happens.
Don't hate the player.
Hate the game.
Yeah.
Cause I gotta I booked the job and uh,
like I said,
some scenes where,
oh boy.
Yeah,
I guess there's a boy,
girl,
boy,
girl.
And then there's like,
um,
I dunno,
there's just a couple blow bangs,
but yeah.
Uh,
I have to shoot those scenes and um,
it's going to make me have to move and loose some live dates,
which whatever,
I can't get into it yet,
but as soon as they get the official word on it,
I will post about it and I'll,
I'll talk about it on the show.
Okay.
They just don't have a signed deal.
So,
but I'm just giving the heads up that it's a,
for them to emotionally,
emotionally prepare yourself,
that I got a job and,
um,
it's at Granger.
Oh Shit.
I shouldn't have said it,
but a good job.
It's a great job.
Got Benefits.
Um,
learning like how the warehouse is laid out where certain things are,
but yeah,
and that's just how it goes gene.
Well,
um,
I hope those people can handle it.
I hope they don't get too emotional,
emotionally troubled by this kind of stuff.
Wow.
There it is guys
and get it ready rob.
Rob,
rob,
the show is about to begin.
We've got a good one.
We've got good guests.
It's going to be fun.
You ready to do this gene?
He's get into it.
Try it out.
Okay,
here we go.
Here we go.
My name is Tracy and you may have seen before,
see men facial tutorial looking into natural remedies,
looking into the benefits,
digesting,
seaman,
scribbling notes.
You knew how to write.
Okay.
You know what's funny about these broads?
I feel like there's every few cycles of life.
It's like,
it's this thing where every now and then some fucking dumb bitch thinks that
she's figured out that the semen cure,
right.
Look to her.
I'll give her that.
She looks great but drop.
But every now and then it's like some stupid bitch gets cum on her face and
she's like,
it's so sad.
I mean,
if people have been doing the Siem and stuff for decades,
they always think they're the first one.
Cause some guy shot a load on your tits and now you think it's medicinal.
Like come on.
Why?
They think that they're the first one always.
You know,
it does that.
It's kind of silly to me that they're like,
I did this.
I figured out the come thing first.
Well,
I mean there's books written with the recipes,
natural harvest.
We've covered that book in the early days of your mom's house.
Semen,
recipes,
semen drinks.
We've invented calm.
Is he here already?
Do you want to get it
all right?
Oppressed?
Yeah.
Like I said too,
we've also built an industry on it,
a common GAM.
Remember that when we,
we wanted the middle,
one of our favorite products that we took on shark tank and people didn't even
see that episode.
Apparently it broke a lot of the broadcast guidelines,
but you know,
we,
we sat there with Mark Cuban and the lights go out and we were like,
you know,
there's everyone likes gum or likes guys were about different flavored gum with
different guys flavors in it.
And then he was like,
okay,
like what about distribution?
And we've got kind of caught up there,
but
well,
and also like the QVC lady really took a shine.
What's her name?
She's like,
I can see this come,
come in every house in America.
Was that Laurie?
Is that her name?
Yeah,
Lori.
She really liked it.
Yeah.
And they,
they all like the free samples we gave them.
They were all aligned on the,
what is it has to Chinese guy,
you know,
that's a black guy.
That's a Puerto Rican guy.
You need to have all their different genes in their mouth.
It was really exciting.
You know,
and I remember reading a vice article on this a decade ago,
whether or not the comm stuff it works as a moisturizer are actually has
nutritional value.
The answer's no,
no,
no.
And you know,
it's,
it's a placebo thing.
These women think that they're,
you know,
doing something big.
Yeah.
Rehmann Jizz on their face or the first one.
It's going to fluid bonding with Jessie
still my favorite.
Those ideas.
Jesus fucking all over my face.
Yeah.
She's another one that's like,
I don't,
I'm empowering myself
on me.
I let him,
I wanted it.
It's so foul as so nasty,
but accidentally before.
Yeah,
of course I laid on my back and shot it over over my head and had some,
but like I'm telling you,
you got to move quick.
You're like,
I gotta get this off.
You don't find it to be medicinal or I didn't even think,
I just always think it's growth.
Of course.
Yeah.
I think my body fluids or gross,
like there's nothing I cherish.
I make so much of it that comes out.
Yeah.
Oh,
you do make a lot of loads.
I mean,
it doesn't bother me.
Like your staff does never bothers me,
but I don't,
I wouldn't want to like put it on my face or,
but some people do though.
I understand that.
That's some people's kink.
Yeah.
You know,
maybe that's what this is being mistaken for.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
He loves this company.
So let's see what she has to say.
Here's her tits are nice.
I've seen that
many rules it to men
play this.
I think we played this before.
No,
not her.
I feel like we have,
there's just,
I'm telling you,
these bitches,
they all think they're new.
This bitch looks familiar.
Yeah.
But I remember her stupid fucking what's her,
uh,
her tattoo.
A cactus on her belly.
Look how stupid I would remember that.
Stupid ass.
Some things that you can do to improve the taste of semen.
God Not Pineapple.
Yes.
We know
you're not the first one you bought.
Yeah.
It's like she just started having sex so she's like,
oh my God.
I think she just knows this is going to get views.
Right.
Cause she wore her.
Yeah.
You wear that and she wears a tinny tiny youtube.
You know,
you're going to get crazy click.
That's true.
We need to use this as the opening the trailer for this episode.
No.
Right.
Yeah.
Diary throughout the day,
whether it's in the morning or last thing at night,
how hydrated you are,
the kind of diets and lifestyle that you haven't done.
I like,
or if there is a dramatic difference in the taste and texture in receiving,
it could be an indication underlying health problems.
No type of scene
since this is um,
you know,
she seems like she's all on board with this.
I wonder if she'd try mine out,
you know,
do you want to mail her?
She's obviously in Australia.
She Australian or nearly kill me.
Well,
do you want to seal it in a jar and then send it across the world?
We try it out.
Try let's find your,
let's find out.
Tracy gets.com.
Tom,
have you been eating bacon?
And I'm like,
yeah hmm,
high fat.
I'm going to trust his badge.
Cause what did,
she's like,
she uses your sperm to get impregnated nicely.
You know,
she's like,
well you know what I would do?
I would say I have to be there to,
to spoon feed you.
You know,
I'll,
I'll spoonfeed you try it out.
So still back and tell her
to be using.
I am not involved in instruction at the scene and I'd just like to cling to
that.
It's fairly new.
I'm done.
I tapped out.
We have done,
we played this and let's not play.
I don't want to see it anymore.
And you don't because old school,
I used to only see the video and
this is nasty.
They've got a little disappointed in blue band.
He would never,
not knowing our back catalog,
our entire 400 episodes of the show.
But yeah,
we've played at Tom.
Look how little that just is.
You make so much more than that.
No,
she would be like holding up like a jar and she'd be like swinging it around.
Big One of those mason jars.
Can you believe this is one guy who's called comedian Tom.
His culture,
overseer,
new special.
Um,
anyways,
we've been a,
I want to get to our topics before our guest shows up.
You know,
just catch people up on what's been happening.
Let's just see.
Anyway,
throw up.
I don't want to watch to see if she,
she or not.
No.
Ooh.
Ooh,
no shit.
Bitch.
Are you talking about dummy stub it?
That's her friends ges and it's all cold and it's been sitting around.
Oh,
my eyes are watering,
right.
Nasty.
These hell bitch.
She's so fucking retarded for that.
Dammit.
I mean it's one thing to eat it fresh out of the oven,
but to have it sitting in a fucking Dixie cap dude.
Fucking foul man.
Kind of bitch.
No Shit,
dummy.
Okay,
I got it.
I did not.
It's making me sick too.
It's so hard to listen to her.
It's not even somebody you fucking love.
You idiot for the health benefits.
Nothing else.
Just health.
Ah.
Anyway,
uh,
we've officially turned into our parents.
We started watching the Olympics,
which I feel like is something your parents did remember,
like back with five channels and that was like the biggest program of course.
And a,
you and I realized just how sexist we both were.
We were watching these snowboarders do all these crazy tracks are a hundred
years old.
First of all,
I was like,
I thought the Olympics were just a bunch of French guys skiing.
How boring is that?
So I never watched it.
Now these fools are doing,
you know,
halfpipe whatever that,
they look like they're skateboarding,
but on snowboards and their chicks man,
and both of us are like,
we're a thousand years old that we didn't know that,
hey,
and that we're amazed that it's like 17 year old girls doing this.
It was so awesome.
We were like,
these girls could do this.
I totally did too.
Like that's not a chick it natureraised farms.
Oh,
I felt so old and I like the Winter Olympics now.
I had no idea how cool it is.
I just had it on in the background and you know,
and I was watching snowboarding stuff and I was like,
that guy's fucking crazy.
And then takes her helmet off and blowing and says,
I'm 16 and I'm in high school.
I know she's well,
I'm a ball hog.
I'm Christine [inaudible] and I'm a Baha'i is super disrespectful.
Why doesn't the Olympics,
these are nice girl.
How could you say that about one of those girls?
They're all,
but they're all ball hogging Shaun white.
He's like the hot shit and he's getting his nuts out.
I'm following him on Instagram and he's taken all the pics with all the cute
blonde skier bitches and all that.
He's,
this is his last one probably,
right?
I mean,
yeah,
for something.
So he's got,
if I were him,
I would just be like on a nut draining mission right now.
Of course,
you know what a fuckers for like six different countries.
I gotta go,
I gotta do it.
I'm like,
he's just trying to close a deal with every country.
He's great,
great mission to accomplish.
And I think he should get a medal for that just for busting nuts and
international.
And that's the kind of thing I could see Trump inviting them to the White House
door call.
I'm like,
I heard you folks from every country I respect to show.
Yeah.
Thank you,
Mr. Yeah.
Yeah.
These fucking bitches are doing it,
man on the snowboards.
I'm like,
um,
you know what I'm saying?
No,
it's incredible.
God Damn,
they're so good.
They're so good.
God Damn it.
It's still so much every time.
And we were watching,
they don't call it figure skating anymore.
It's called ice dancing.
I don't know when that fucking lame shit happened.
That shit.
So we were watching this as a,
as it aired the Frenchies.
I thought the,
I thought the back broke it,
it just,
it's all good.
Nip slip though.
Not In the back did break because it was around her neck.
So what happened was these Frenchies they were,
they were ice dancing and her costume came down because it wasn't latched on
properly around her neck.
And I guess her teddy popped it.
I didn't even see that live,
but I have less Eugene.
But I was thinking to myself,
she's gotta be so distracted by that man.
But they did a great skate despite that.
Do you think he's gets,
do you think he's gay?
Do you think any of these guys ice dancing on a straight straight,
I feel bad for it.
Or actually,
you know,
course work so hard.
How do you not have that shit?
Like triple check that you're going to be in the Olympics and you're like,
Hey,
uh,
I want to make sure my teddy doesn't pop out.
I'm telling you,
you know when you're performing at a high stakes thing like this,
you make sure everything is sewn onto you of course,
that they should have sown that.
I don't know why someone didn't really make sure.
Poor girl.
And of course she's French so she's like,
ah,
manipulate.
Yeah,
of course.
She didn't even give a shit.
Probably Lillian,
this guy,
my beard,
I think he does some nice and easy.
It's real dark.
It's pretty dark,
really dark.
He's totally straight,
totally straight and the ass cheeks on these guys.
Oh my God,
look like little end tables.
Perfect.
These guys can go rest all your keys or wallet for days.
Everything on that ass.
Credible ice dancing.
Can we start ice dancing?
You and I,
I would.
I wouldn't mind.
I would love.
Okay,
here's my proposal.
You,
Ari,
Joe Burt.
Next challenge.
Figure skating.
I'm sorry.
Ice Dancing.
And I want all you guys to learn how to sow cow and twizzle.
I want to see you guys and Leotards twizzler Lang.
Let's see,
what did they still end up placing or no?
I don't know.
Moyer and what's start face a distracting kind of my worst nightmare.
That's a poor girl,
man.
That's terrible.
This is what I could do.
That they stayed relatively calm.
That landed him in second blow of a right.
They got second after they skated.
Did they maintain that's what I don't know.
Cause those Canadians really killed it.
Maybe that is just to get into the placement thing.
Oh right.
Just to,
yeah,
right to compete or whatever.
I don't know.
But they had those Canadians.
They are really had a hard on for them.
They scored really high those till June.
I just saw this thing that popped up.
Well what's that?
And then we watched that show sometimes where that couple flips houses.
Yeah,
they split.
I know.
I've been hearing that on us.
Christine Mussa.
No,
no,
no.
Not that.
The one that we make fun of.
Chip and shut up.
Yeah.
We called that though.
You and I called this because she has total contempt for him.
Every time he fucking opens his mouth that show her eyes roll so far back into
her head,
you can't even hide it.
He's always like,
do you love me?
Oh my God.
He loves her so much.
He does.
Yeah.
No.
And they have like five kids,
six or uppers.
The name of the show.
Fuck yeah.
Knew it.
She hates him.
The feeling that she has already conquered than a fixer upper children together.
What did a lot of kids?
Yeah.
I mean he adores her,
but you can tell.
So I know he,
she fucking hates him because every time he tries to be funny and cute on the
show,
like he acts like a little boy and you can see she the contempt and her,
she hates his sense of humor and hates it.
He's childish and stuff cause he'll like,
you know,
throw a hammer through a wall and be like,
ah.
And just she see that,
I don't,
I'm not understanding this.
This just says they're pregnant to ah,
what are they quitting the show or quitting the time?
The show.
Oh God.
Well now I know,
but I'm,
I mean,
I'm reading the thing that it says here.
Who knows what this fucking means?
Yeah.
This is like a,
God damn.
How many kids is that Nem?
The Ham,
like their fifth child,
the they need to stop any more than four is a cult.
That's not okay.
Yeah,
so they're not splitting.
She's,
she doesn't want to do the show anymore.
Oh,
shut up.
You know what?
I hate people like that.
Like you've got your fucking gravy train.
Make your money,
bitch.
Do the show until they stopped paying you.
All right.
Am I right?
You're lucky that you're on a show that they must make a good living now.
Fuck you.
Okay.
Walk away from it.
You dumb dumb.
That's stupidity.
That's so stupid.
Do the show until the fucking no one wants to see you doing that stupid show.
Right,
man,
we're going to do this show until no one wants to listen to us talk about
farting.
It's not just about farting hate.
When people say that.
Speaking of you and I had a very in depth discussion the other day at the
breakfast table over which body functions you and I prefer the most.
Right?
Because you actually really enjoy your body functions.
You're sneezing things.
Every time you sneezed you're like,
ah,
such a good sneeze tight.
Yeah.
Every time you fart and you're like,
oh,
it was a good farther was a kitchen and I don't enjoy them as much as you do.
I don't really,
to me it's just relief of suffering.
Like when I take a shit,
it's just,
it's only really isn't relief of suffering.
Enjoyment.
No,
it's relief and joy are two different feelings.
For me,
relief is like,
Oh God,
I'm not hurting anymore.
That can be a joyful experience to feel the relief.
Oh my God.
Oh God,
it feels so good.
He liked that.
So what's your,
let's rank your body functions.
I don't know.
Cause sometimes I feel like after I sneeze I feel like I just just right.
You love,
you get that head rush ahead.
I I could almost go to sleep right after a good sneeze.
Now,
sometimes I,
and I think it's associated with,
um,
maybe a food reaction and it'll,
I'll sneeze sneeze.
It feels all right,
but it really fuck up my,
my,
uh,
breathing.
In other words,
I feel like it irritated air passage,
you know,
so it's like air gets trapped.
Then I'm like,
ah,
it's just not as their different style sneezes.
But if it's a pure sneeze,
sunlight induced sneeze,
you know,
walk outside and boom,
boom,
boom.
And I get a few going.
I really relish that feeling.
I enjoy it.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
You and I are vastly different
when it sit there in the sun and kind of let it sit.
You know,
I really want to,
I mean I feel like it's like almost orgasmic.
I feel like body functions are just,
um,
an unwelcome interruption into whatever I'm doing.
Like the body is a hindrance to everything I want to be doing.
You're cleansing with a Q tip.
I like that.
I love cleaning my ears.
Burps sometimes.
See,
I was going to say now you're not like you're already on board again.
Well the,
the thing is I like Burks.
I feel like burps are fun.
They create joy for other people.
You can compete,
you can challenge yourself and get good at them.
You know what I mean?
Like I like those.
Yeah.
But everything else about my body,
just an inconvenience.
You never enjoyed the feeling of a sneeze?
I don't enjoy it now I get,
I get scared because I'm losing control.
I don't like it.
I don't like that after kind of buzz from a sneeze,
you know?
Talking about no.
Know what I'm saying?
No,
really.
I don't relish my body functions to know you ask you if you don't relish.
I'm saying,
do you ever get,
have a sneeze when you feel kind of light headed after a sneeze?
No,
never.
I mean,
I don't think so.
I don't,
I don't notice it.
I don't care.
That's the thing.
I'm not paying attention.
Okay.
I'm just asking you if like you have the same experience.
I don't.
I'm telling you that I just get through it so that I can get onto the next
thing.
Like I'm not even thinking about how that sneeze,
just inconvenience it took second out of my life.
I am no fun.
I have no joy.
Uh,
just things like that.
I don't care.
You're always doing that.
I like farting.
I like burning Burbank.
Okay.
So you enjoy a couple of bobcats?
They're loud and they interrupt things.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean,
you're making it sound like you're like,
I'm not on board with any of this.
And then two minutes later you're like,
I'm actually pretty into these two things.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
I guess,
I guess what you and I have different,
I don't know.
You're saying that you think that I enjoy them more.
Yeah.
I feel like you really savor a sneeze or you savor the shit and I just don't.
I,
to me,
those are two things that I just want to get over with so that I can move on to
the next,
but a burp is kind of welcome to because it's fun.
Everyone's going to like it.
I don't know if everyone's gonna like,
it's gonna make my,
you know,
it'll upset my mom.
Those kinds of thoughts.
It's a good feelings.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hey,
same strokes for everybody.
Tom.
Everyone's the same.
It's the same for,
um,
okay.
I have to say that I do enjoy pretty much all of them.
Yeah.
I also enjoy like a nice long post,
you know?
Yeah.
It's relief associated to those,
but that's the difference for me.
I think the Relief Association,
cause I'm in,
you're in torture and then I don't find relief to be the same as the joy of a
burp.
A burp is,
there's a,
you know,
it's just fun.
It's frivolous.
Yeah.
Just like a fart.
A fire.
It's just,
it's just there to say hi.
You have,
I mean it's okay how you're fart.
Oh yeah.
Say Hi.
Okay.
That's fine.
There you go.
There it is.
I'm just thinking about it,
you know,
I feel like I enjoy all the bodily functions.
You tail well,
enjoy picking my nose.
I do like picking why now?
Now you're at another one that you're in today.
Is that a body function or it's something gross you do?
It's kind of,
it was kind of unnecessary at times.
I like some hygiene things.
I do like cleaning my ears and I do like picking my nose a lot.
Yeah.
Well,
I like talking and burping.
Do you also like it?
You don't realize how much in on the same thing you really are.
I know.
I just feel like you,
but I'm saying that your level of enjoyment is higher than my expressing joy.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't see,
I think you still enjoy it.
You just don't express it.
Yeah,
but I don't feel a lot of things.
We know this.
This is why we're comedians not,
and don't you feel are take joy.
Joy is a feeling.
I'm not comfortable with feelings.
You know that.
I've been in therapy for 10 years.
Okay,
so we're going to happen.
I don't,
I don't have the same sensitivity to things.
Whoa.
This is so off the showing a feeling you're saying?
No,
I just said expressing.
I didn't say,
Oh yeah,
no,
you enjoy it.
You're just not expressing it.
I guess you were expressing it.
Now you're like,
I do like it.
So you do enjoy it.
You just don't express it as much in the moment.
I guess,
but I don't,
I don't enjoy,
I don't enjoy sneezing.
Okay.
We press pause,
pause,
and now we're back.
Oh,
it's blocking you.
There you go.
You got to see my tits,
tits
and our guests.
Johnny Pemberton is here.
Thank you.
Pepper.
10 next.
Sorry.
Johnny pepper is here.
Come all over my face.
That's how I feel now that I said it wrong.
Actually.
Pemberton.
You're right.
Got David.
So fucking with me man.
He's
from a push down rates state of Minnesota,
Wisconsin.
And He,
um,
where are you from?
The Greater,
the greater what?
Minneapolis area.
Now I'm from Rochester.
It's like a,
it's like a medium size.
I already know about the Mayo Clinic.
You fucking show off.
There you go.
That's it.
That's all.
We've got some male clinic.
You have premium healthcare.
I mean it's not premium.
It's above premium.
It's like diamond.
I'm in the diamond diamond,
diamond platinum.
Did you ever go just to be like,
hey,
I got a cold.
You can't see.
They could do.
My Dad was a doctor,
so yeah,
he's a,
sorry.
He still works there.
Yeah.
After Pemberton.
Doctor Pemberton,
bad growing up with a dad doctor.
I Dunno.
I think it's kind of depends.
My Dad was a surgeon,
so surgeons are basically completely not helpful for anything at all.
Like if I ask,
if I say something like I have a Coleman that's like,
I don't know,
I'm just,
I take this try.
It just nothing is no,
unless than less.
It can be fixed with a knife.
It's something you can't fake.
What is his specialty?
He's a colon rectal surgeon.
Get the fuck out of here.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
That's what he says to this shit.
So he does a lot of um,
making you,
uh,
your,
you know,
your shit come through your side,
whatever it is.
Well,
he does all that stuff.
Yeah.
Well he like put me installing a stoma or like an illegal anal anastomosis.
Shit.
Shit is right.
I read,
um,
this book about sociopath's and said there was a,
it's a cool segue.
I want to say this is going disproportionate.
Um,
higher number of surgeons have,
yeah,
yeah.
I guess I can see that.
Not that obviously that all are,
but just like some of the guys were like kind of a good job for associate path
cause you can kind of totally emotionally he died and so we went to lunch.
Well maybe it makes you a sociopath because you have to be that way because if
you don't,
if you have like an attachment to your patients and you're a surgeon,
it's like you wouldn't be able to handle that shit.
Yeah,
that's true.
Oh Dude.
Weeping all the tall.
Yeah.
I don't know how,
I mean,
I don't know how they do it,
period.
Whether or not they're sociopath's.
Um,
they've gotten,
it's gotten hard.
I've seen an operation once and it was something where it was before it was back
when they still allowed that like allowed family to watch an operation.
Now they don't allow that shit anymore.
It's like,
it's really locked down.
Like very,
um,
it's a lot of administration there,
but when you see it,
it doesn't seem gross at all.
There's like a real disconnect between if you watch someone getting,
having surgery at home on TV,
it's 10 times more gross.
And makes you more squeamish than if you were just there because you were there.
It's kind of like,
it's normal.
I went and watched a bunch of surgeries one day at the Mayo Clinic in
Jacksonville.
He's serious.
Yeah.
Because why?
My uncle worked at the Mayo clinic in Rochester.
He did what's his last name?
Okay.
And um,
he,
uh,
so I told,
I had the bright idea
that I wanted to be a doctor when I was like,
before the band.
Yeah.
This is pretty bad.
Pretty bad.
So this is like,
you know,
I was an eighth grade,
ninth grade and I'm like,
I want to be a doctor.
So I call my,
I tell my dad,
my dad calls his brother and he arranges for me to go to the Mayo Clinic in
Jacksonville,
which is like,
you know,
the sister
been there.
Yeah.
I've had my,
I've had my ass looked at there.
Yeah.
You're the son of the colon surgeons.
Highly Ironic.
I had,
I actually had a had colitis.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
I know I,
my colon removed too,
so.
Yeah,
I know it's nuts.
That was a long time when I was about 17,
maybe 17 years ago or so.
That sounds so rare,
right?
Yeah.
It's super rare and weird,
but it's also just,
um,
I dunno.
Yeah,
irony.
The irony is incredible.
It's really deep.
We had like a friend do it basically.
It was weird because I knew everyone has done in his department,
right?
Like,
cause we grew up together and like had the uh,
the cnrs picnic,
which stands for colon rectal surgery picnic that you never put on a sign
because no one wants to go to the colon rectal surgery picnic.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I knew all of his friends are fine.
Uh,
I guess so.
I mean I was,
I was sick for a long time though,
so it wasn't like something where it was more like a relief kind of thing.
And Yeah,
I dunno.
Some about surgery,
it's so overwhelming that
is it like would he,
because he's so knowledgeable in that particular field,
was it like more comforting that he's like telling you the ins and outs of
what's going to happen as far as the surgery went?
Like how it's going to go.
Like cause I mean he obviously is really well versed but most dads be like,
it's all right buddy,
you know,
kind of my hair.
I'm
trying to think.
I don't want it.
Don't remember it that well in terms of that stuff.
I think a,
he said some stuff,
I don't even fucking know you have a,
when you want the full download.
Okay.
What happens is you have,
well from my case at least they were able to do something where they basically
reroute it back through your asshole again.
But,
but there's two surgeries.
The first surgery they take the colon out and they establish um,
you have like a stoma,
you have like a,
you know,
you poop out of your abdomen because everything has to heal up.
What they do is they take the ending of your small intestine and it makes them,
he called the j pouch cause it's the shape of a j.
And that is your new sort of like rectum,
like your rectum.
Everyone thinks rectum is actually your anus.
Rectum is technically like sort of like the the loading dock to the last part of
the colon.
So they basically make that out of the ending of your small intestine.
But as it heals up that they can't have shit that going through it.
So there you have the bag.
I had a colostomy bag for maybe about 10 weeks or saw my God.
Yeah and it sucks but it's also one of the things where there's people who have
their entire life.
Half of that thing I just had temporarily.
And I assume then that you go back in for a second.
Yeah,
the second was not as bad and they reconnect everything and then you know when
you wake up they're like once your bowels wake up cause your bowels will go to
sleep if they could touched it sounds so weird.
Maybe touch your bows.
Like if you were somehow to able to go inside your abdomen and touch your
bowels,
they just go,
they just stop.
They stop working for like 24 hours.
That's like a,
it's like a defense mechanism against in case you get like a bowel perforation
or something like that.
Wow.
Isn't that fascinating?
So you don't shit for a while.
So.
So does your asshole go dormant when it's like not my asshole.
Yeah.
Or like anyone's who has the rerouting.
In other words it's like,
well no,
I mean I don't have,
I mean it's,
it's fully functional now.
No,
I'm saying when this window,
yeah.
So it's like there's no use to it.
Well Mucus still comes out so he's still like shit.
Every once in a while you're like,
what's that feeling?
You have to shit.
And it feels really weird.
The first time I do it it's just like,
cause your body produces fluids in any sort of negative space and you've got to
get them out so you,
you shit out like some mucus.
So fascinated in like so uncomfortable.
It's a weird thing.
It's terrible.
Like the classmate bag is one of those things that is a,
it's the worst thing,
but it's also kind of deeply fascinating cause it's so fucking bad.
It's so terrible.
It's like this thing where like I had,
um,
there,
the crazy thing about classmate bag is that the waste that comes out,
it's not like regular shit.
Why wait?
It's worse.
Like,
Oh,
I'm going to shit.
And then it goes out of the colostomy bag.
It's all,
it's like who's there?
You're like a little,
sometimes you're like a little gurgling or maybe nothing at all.
But either way it's kind of,
um,
wait,
what does it look like again?
So you're saying it,
what does it look like?
It's not regular shit.
You said it's,
Oh,
well,
it's sort of like,
um,
I,
I always liken it to if you went to a sausage factory in inner and walked in
when before they were finished making it,
it's like this is,
this is the worst part.
It's worse than the,
what they start with.
And it's obviously worse than the ending because it's really,
you're like interrupting a natural process and so it's like,
we're not done yet.
It's fucking terrible.
It's like,
yeah,
I mean,
uh,
it's something where if you could,
if you could bottle that you could clear out,
you could clear a space out pretty quickly.
She goes,
you would probably,
you should brought on an airplane.
It would,
they have to land,
you would have to,
I feel like maybe,
maybe,
well yeah cause they just did it this week.
Somebody was farting and they look away.
He's serious.
They landed a plane cause someone's foreign.
When he refused to stop,
it wasn't about the farting stop farting.
Well he was asked to stop or other passengers and then a fight broke out over it
and then they landed the plane.
Oh,
so it's the fight.
It was the fight.
It was the part that broke the window.
They literally broke the,
it was pretty bad.
Yeah.
It was a pretty bad for us with the reports.
Wait,
so I was,
I was telling you though,
and saw surgeries I witnessed,
like you saw surgeries,
I saw many surgeries,
how many surgeries and I saw they were all in the um,
um,
urinary tract.
Okay.
Come on.
So I,
I basically had a,
I watch like this,
the first one was this 87 year old woman that had a cyst the size of a golf
ball.
Oh,
that's not very big.
Really?
No,
no,
no.
Sorry.
Softball.
Okay.
There you go.
Now.
And then they were like,
this is a record setter.
What brought,
brought in cameras and then the guide,
the surgeon was like,
hey,
just don't,
don't say anything to her.
And they'll be like,
oh,
you're a pussy is gross if she's awake.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
Oh,
she's awake.
Yeah.
That's weird.
Yeah,
she was awake.
Yeah.
It was gnarly.
And then I kept,
you know,
went to the next one,
the next one,
the next day.
It was a full day of it.
And Damn.
I was like,
I don't,
I don't know man.
I don't know if I could do this.
Actually.
Yeah,
it would be hard.
I think
I wouldn't let that happen if I were awake and some punk ass kids were in there
as my pussy was getting operated on.
But it's a teaching hospital.
They ask you,
they're like,
hey,
so we want,
we're so good because we let people,
we got to watch.
And so will you let him watch so he can be good?
Absolutely not.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I guess if for a pussy surge,
I would say no.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's bad enough when you give birth.
And I was pushing my son out,
uh,
Ellis and they had a shift change.
So like for nurses changed as I was pushing out my son,
nothing related to eight people get to see my posts right now.
Blasted.
So,
but can I ask you,
since these,
these many years that this has happened,
um,
everything is cool now.
I mean,
it's never,
it's never going to be like,
it's cool.
It's like a dude who takes a big dump once a day kind of thing.
I always think of like some old dude who's really sweaty and a golf course,
you know,
I gotta go take a dig boys.
It takes like some giant fucking ropey thing that has been sitting in there for
a week after a steakhouse visit.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I'll never have that.
But I guess watch what you eat.
Yeah.
I kinda like religiously do it,
but it's not,
I don't think about it.
I'm just,
I know.
Yeah.
What can't you eat?
Things that are bad.
I mean I'm,
anything that's greasy or,
uh,
I mean for me,
my favorite thing that I love buffalo wings.
Yeah.
But when I eat them,
it's like this thing where I'm either hurting myself because I'd done something
wrong.
I need to be punished or I'm like,
okay,
so I know there's going to be held to pay for this,
but it's going to taste really good right now.
But 10 hours from now I'm going to wake up and I'm going to be having extreme
hot exits at 4:00 AM where it's like,
yeah,
it's going to hurt because it's like what happens is I think w with the spice,
a lot of times the spices get broken down.
The longer your intestines are.
So mine are shorter,
so don't get a chance to get it
broken as much.
So when they still got their fucking swords when it's so hot.
Yeah.
Cause you need that real estate to really work to mellow with the nutrition out
of your poops.
Yeah.
Tony,
what are the disadvantages of looking attorney 16?
Like give us,
well,
I'd say advantages is I'm having people talk down to you constantly having
consistent customer service problems because you're treated like a child and a
first timer on for anything you possibly do,
even though you're older than the person you guaranteed.
Um,
basically that,
I would say that that's where the upside is just consistently being treated as
though you have a,
it's your first day on earth.
Sort of like,
you know,
that's a,
I never thought of that young man.
Why don't you relax and you're like,
I'm like,
Gosh,
that,
but there are sometimes it is good because I feel like people won't be,
won't be mean to me.
Oh yeah.
Like I can get away with a lot of,
I can get with a lot of shit.
I go,
well you know I can get away with is being an Ada so I can,
I can plead,
I'm like if I'm at an airport,
a lot of times I will uh,
steal a bottle of water because I don't want to pay for a bottle of water.
Cause I feel like,
cause it's like a multinational corporation selling it.
They're not losing anything from where do you steal it from?
It depends.
Like if you're in line at Starbucks or something like that,
just grab it and just hold it.
And if you,
if you pretend it's yours,
it's yours.
What I mean and so,
and let's just say I were to take like 15,
15 bottles of water.
Yeah.
And walk away.
And someone,
someone were to actually say,
excuse me sir,
Sir ag would just turn around and go,
Oh,
oh I'm sorry I didn't,
I didn't really,
I didn't pay for these.
I'm sorry,
I'm so confused.
I'm just really tired.
I didn't think there would be nothing.
What happened?
Yeah.
Cause I just sort of just lying can just turn around and just look wide.
I just feel like what,
what?
Oh,
these are,
oh,
I thought these were mine.
My Dad get these.
They're like,
oh,
it's okay.
It's okay.
It's okay sometimes,
but I don't you do that,
that author and cause it's Kinda like a weird thing where it's like that whole
abyss stares back sort of thing where I feel like anytime you live in something
that's certain way,
like if you're an actor and you add play a character,
you can say it's a character all you want,
but it's going to become your life come part of your life.
So it's,
um,
it's,
it's gotta be an advantage and disadvantage at times with your acting too.
Yeah,
it's both,
I guess.
Probably because of it.
Right.
And you're going to be not considered because of it,
I guess.
I mean,
I don't only play a,
I mean you said 16.
I don't play the 16.
I know you're exaggerating.
You're a comedian,
right?
Sometimes I,
yeah,
and I exaggerate and indulge really,
you,
I mean,
every,
that's weird.
I mean,
I just take everything I hear at face value.
I,
it's weird.
I assume that everything everyone says,
it's like,
oh,
they mean that completely.
100% there's no such thing as satire or like hyperbole.
No,
it doesn't exist.
No irony.
Sarcasm doesn't exist.
No.
Yup,
that's good.
It sounds like you're,
you get it man.
I'm just,
you know what I see is what I believe and that's,
I'm just now papers.
Jean,
did you know that a new case has been brought to our attention
of foreign accents?
I hide the,
my voice in the conversation for nearly four year now.
This was sent to a,
that's the original that became oh,
so popular on this show.
Yeah.
And then I actually did a bit about it on my latest Netflix special.
I talked about foreign accent syndrome and because of that I started getting a
lot of messages from people about it.
And then it was in the news last week and it was send it to us.
Many.
Yeah.
Very exciting.
Now Johnny,
are you familiar with that?
I am familiar with this and I still can't believe it's a real thing.
I feel like it's gotta be some sort of a brain trauma or something.
Yeah.
I can't believe she's dressed like Minnie mouse.
Look at her.
Yeah,
that's perfect.
Everyone only sees um,
or,
oh,
he,
Mary Poppins,
not a British nanny.
This former Texas beauty,
the USA who would do this for attention?
I don't know,
three times.
Michelle Myers has gone to sleep with blinding headaches,
waking up with different accents.
Irish,
Australian and British for the past couple of years.
They send in the psychiatrist at the hospital,
you know,
they make sure you're not alone.
Not Crazy,
not faking it.
She was diagnosed with foreign accent syndrome,
a rare condition that usually accompanies a stroke.
Neurological damage or underlying health issue.
It's kind of funny to me that,
um,
we picked us up on the other one is that it's not just an accent,
but then their grammar,
the word.
Yeah.
And host balloon at hospital.
Make sure you're not alone.
We don't say no,
you know?
No,
but that's,
but that's just,
I mean,
sorry,
but that,
that also kind of whatever speaks to the authenticity of foreign accents.
I don't pick up the grammatical,
but you're going to pick up colloquialisms.
Yeah.
See that to me that means something different than just the way you're speaking.
Right.
So it has to be learned.
Yeah,
because like the,
the,
the Chinese accent,
she would be,
she would say grammatically incorrect thing.
Right.
She was speaking English as though she were like a Chinese person learning,
learning English.
I have on not that actually had my
three year now.
Like they know what she did,
didn't speak English like that right now I wonder to native speakers,
whatever,
does it sound proper?
Like is her accent good?
I'm going to say,
I'm going to say no.
As a person who likes accents a lot.
Like to add to an annoying degree.
Yeah.
I'm calling no on that one.
Really?
Yeah.
I would have to say as,
as somebody who also enjoys accents,
it doesn't feel like she's
like,
which part of England is she from?
She sounds like she's from like a sort of a semi posh area of the Midlands or
London.
Wow.
Specific Johnny.
Well,
cause she's,
she's not doing like the uh,
the whole like oh from north London,
may from the flock and north London.
Oh,
right,
right.
Yeah.
That's how we do here.
Fuck off.
That's good.
Sod off from your and all.
You got these people who live in like,
um,
like with Jon Snow's from,
I did a movie,
this girl who was from there,
it's like God,
their accents.
So annoying.
Kind of.
It's like God,
I came and think,
oh mom's here for,
why are we going to go there?
Oh well great to be here with you.
It's like this weird mixture of Scottish and Irish.
Is that accent considered?
Well the one you just did like a lower class.
I think it depends.
Collar the posh.
That's think that depends on I think,
um,
I don't think so.
Cause that's more of a regional one.
I can't think of they call it.
Um,
but we have a master of access.
We can do it next week.
You can recall.
I want to ask you the salt,
we were watching that movie about Winston Churchill last night.
Right.
And I noticed the royals,
they speak in the very,
this big highest,
Hey,
I'm good shouting at standing it,
Shannon,
Ciao.
Hey.
I noticed that sometimes they don't,
they don't do their ours,
right.
They go uh,
the web or whatever.
Well that's because in uh,
you're allowed to have a list there.
It's not considered a speech impediment or speech impediment.
Is it still like that or was that still is it was just talk show host him grant
things.
Graham Norton,
he has a,
he's a full on list and he's like,
I think his grandma,
there's definitely a guy on TV in the UK who has a list and it's just,
that's considered like just how you talk because I remember that TV show.
Do you remember the young ones?
I don't know if you ever saw that as they used to make fun of that Viviane some
guy would always do it like,
like it was a posh thing to do.
I'm like,
oh that makes sense.
Maybe it is,
maybe it's posh cause you can get away with it.
It's like,
I'm so rich,
I don't have to change the way I speak or something.
Yeah,
that could be.
It said British chip Chabot.
I used to always go to my mom and my bones had the stack of medical papers.
As Michelle also has ehlers,
Danlos Syndrome joints and master doctors can tell it turned her British,
British love that to be the result of something that happened to me.
What she used to sound like.
These are always fascinating.
Looking back at how she used to be is difficult today.
I want to encourage you,
so what do you think when you hear that?
I'm sad.
Why does it make you sad?
I guess you still having your head different path.
Can you say something?
Personality thing.
She was standing in front of a massive weed plant and that previous video,
which she really,
yeah,
I'm pretty sure that was.
If it wasn't,
it was like,
ah,
right.
Oh yeah,
so you're a,
what about that?
She's staying in front of Ganja plant.
We just have a big druggie problem here.
I smoked a bunch of weed and the whole
too much.
Downton Abbey.
That's what happens to me.
If I watch that.
Sally,
what's that show that came out on Netflix?
The cloud.
The one,
the one that gets me all the time.
It's like the old cowboy movies when they have the southern.
I just want like live in that.
I watched that one.
The old southern,
the cowboy.
We've got to get on down here before.
If you don't,
if you don't find a way out of here.
We look from hell to breakfast at night.
Found nothing but dust and dust and tumbleweeds.
Ahh,
here.
Oh heck.
It sounds like a lot of,
wow.
I would love to just wake up.
I would love to have that to wake up.
I,
I don't know.
I grew up in Minnesota.
America is how I am,
but you know,
y'all want to get some beer.
I'm just,
I'm sick and tired.
Drinking water today.
Stars Day.
I'm just,
I,
I just plum sick of it.
I had a new is how they thought it'd be great if it wasn't just an accident was
like a different time period.
Like he has an accent from the 1920s and Texas.
Those southern expressions are the man.
It's the greatest.
It's the absolute greatest thing I ever like.
Some of those leaders and plum juice and all that shit.
Like you're like,
who?
Who comes up with this shit?
But it's all in the lexicon down.
We got,
oh you can come on here,
but it's cash on the barrel head here son.
We don't take credit or we don't take credit or check it's cash on the barrel
head or you walk do,
you can come.
You can come loaded to bear,
but we were going to turn you out.
Wow.
I just think about it a lot.
It's like,
it's like a,
it's like a brain massage almost.
I feel like.
Were you an only child?
No.
First Child.
Same thing.
Almost sometimes.
Dude told me,
he's like,
you know,
my daddy told me one time,
he said no.
My Dad said you called me daddy when were tomboys me last time he comes out your
mouth.
I didn't even understand that.
He was saying,
you said he got mad at you cause I got got to the age where he's don't say daddy
no more.
So it was like seven,
seven.
I was like,
so he was saying,
he's like,
he said he's going to whip the bit me to the white meat,
mid down the white meat boy.
You don't say daddy no more like,
okay man.
Well,
you know,
cy day and no more.
You now say,
daddy no more.
I tell you what,
this guy from Tennessee east to say to tears in a bucket.
Fuck it.
Oh my God,
that's good.
I like that.
Wow.
I knew a guy.
I'm an engineer in Minnesota who would smoke a cigarette and three drags,
never wore a jacket all winter,
and he had some crazy expressions.
He's really into a tractor pulling.
He'd be like,
Oh yeah,
oh,
going on.
They're firing frauds letters today.
Or we say it's like a,
Oh,
you couldn't catch me five ways.
A Friday on that thing.
Finally talking about,
man,
his name was Dale Dale Mann.
Dale had a lot of traction pulling magazines in the shitter.
I love that expression.
Um,
I heard it for what?
Canadian first when he said like,
ah Buddy,
he looks like 10 pounds of shit in a five pound bag.
I like that.
I've never heard that
when I was like,
that's a good script.
Her Canadians,
same things.
Minnesota.
Yeah.
Pretty close.
Close enough.
Here's the last one.
Hold on.
Let's see.
But her outlook is sunny.
Um,
what?
What?
What is but wondering if the sound of her voice,
am I talking like this will never change again.
Oh,
is that I dunno.
Psychedelic and weird.
So weird.
Tim and Eric turned her British.
That's the best part of that whole thing.
That it's just silly.
Turned her British.
No,
not really.
That's it.
That'd be a cool way to wake up as you talk.
Like you're introducing this segment.
I just can't find its parking.
We're here and we just can't seem to find a way out of the store.
Excuse me.
Do you know where they keep air freshener?
He couldn't answer the question.
Oh God.
It was being spoken to them as though they didn't know.
If you don't take that on stage,
you're an ass.
It's mine.
I just got it.
And it's mine now.
What'd you rather for Johnny?
What's that?
Okay.
What'd you rather talk in that exact,
the TV show,
news caster announcement.
The Chris Hansen from dateline NBC.
You have to fight like that to your wife too.
When you go on stage to do your act,
everything is inland and the life,
all of life and you can't tell people why because it's a would you rather or
would you rather shout everything?
Definitely shout
like shout or scream.
Shoutings different than screaming,
right?
Yeah,
I kind of is because there's,
there's people who do live the shouters people who are like,
I'm loud.
That's trail.
You sleep over.
My sisters are shouting.
Yeah,
they are God.
Well I'm going to say screamer and I was like,
oh my God,
I can't handle it down and belligerent.
We a know Tom and I are low talkers.
That's why we're married cause we can practically whisper to each other.
It's true.
I'm a low toggle too loud.
I can't stand.
It's almost like a,
I feel like it's like a fault where I can't.
If I can't have a conversation in a place where I'm not being overheard,
oh my God,
I may not be able to take that call from a place I come get.
So like I don't want to be,
this girl used to know who lived across the street from us when we lived
downtown years ago and she would um,
we were watching a movie in our apartment.
Right.
She'd take a phone call sitting in the middle of the couch during the movie and
just so totally oblivious.
No.
What,
how are you,
how do you do that?
I don't know.
It's one of those things where I wish they could understand that perspective.
I always make me crazy.
This is all,
everything's back to childhood where I would watch,
it'd be watching a movie and I'm just like focused on the television washing it
and my sister were just walking room and be like,
Hey Tommy,
do you want to go later on to the,
over to the park with it.
I'd be like,
you know,
like my hand and be like,
she's like,
hey,
hello.
And I'm like,
dude,
can you see that I'm watching something?
Right.
And she'd be like,
so do you want to go or not?
I'm going to,
I'm like,
hold on,
I gotta stop this.
I gotta rewind it.
Like,
why would you disrespect?
You know,
like,
why would you just say like,
Hey,
can I ask you something?
Right.
It's just always like right into it.
It would make me crazy man.
Fucking crazy.
I don't think I actually took a nap in my life until I went to college.
Yeah.
Because I'm so used to my mom always like checking off like,
oh,
what's going on?
Why I hate what's going over there.
It was gone and when I had it,
I could actually lay down and not be disturbed.
It was like,
Holy Shit.
Yeah,
you can take an,
I can.
I've never,
never took a nap before.
Then at the same thing,
by the way,
my,
uh,
siblings would do on like,
I'm on the phone holding the phone.
I'm like,
yeah.
So I guess later and they would just be like,
Tommy,
do you want to go to,
I'm like the Tommy Tom on the phone.
Like you don't see that I'm on the phone.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm asking you something and I'm like,
why wouldn't you be like,
oh,
I'll wait until he's done talking on the phone?
I guess it's good.
I was ignored most of my childhood.
Oh Dude,
totally alone.
I took naps and it makes me know,
talks to me when I'm on the phone.
Um,
you know what I hate is people that take cell phone conversations on
speakerphone.
Uh,
like in the airport.
Oh,
you said,
hey,
those people are psychotic.
Yeah,
I would,
if that ever happens,
if I ever see that,
I immediately go,
oh,
I'm involved in this too.
Everyone is just to walk up and be like,
ah.
I just love,
I love like just walking up as close as I can just join again.
Yeah.
Actually Know Jim,
we thought that that wasn't going to work because they did.
The deliverables aren't ready.
I was like,
what the fuck you man,
it's you.
And it's always that conversation.
It's never anything interesting.
You know,
it's every like,
should I break up with him?
I don't know.
Let's take her off of life support.
It's like video.
We were going through my phone the other day and it's me at the airport.
Remember taking,
I'm in the Dallas airport and I'm looking at this film like what is this?
And it's cause it's old.
It's from like a year and a half ago and I'm taking a leak and then like you,
you just hear a loud guy,
a guy saying a business call and the shitter in this shit.
And then like,
he's like,
well we'll arrive on Tuesday and uh,
if we don't have those,
uh,
the p six teens,
then a Wednesday at the latest,
I think you hear like fart flush,
sing.
He's like,
absolutely,
absolutely no,
I mean we're,
we want to get it to you guys.
You know,
I just making a video of them like how crazy is this guy?
What is your working too?
He would just now look,
I feel like you might be able to take my title on this.
It's not,
I didn't expect this,
but I feel like you're so good at this.
That might actually happen.
We don't know.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Tom Segura,
master of accents,
Hebert tend to hear for the title.
Uh,
we didn't know what was gonna happen,
but here it is.
Master of accidents.
What's going on with this man from Liverpool?
We got on and off
is owns it all and got to be fire dog to even to last game.
How's your vision monkeys?
These are goddamn monkeys.
I'll see what's happening here.
Yeah,
these are brothers,
probably twins.
And they just mumble like hell yeah.
You didn't park the bushy play.
Can I fall football takes off.
Is it just one Noel called?
Cause you do it.
I'm thrilled.
Yeah,
the fucking learn half that the stayed in.
I mean,
all the railroad,
there's a few words in our language that I picked up on,
but not that many.
I know.
It's really,
really thick.
Let's see.
Um,
I'll see if I can do this.
So,
all right,
here is a,
the email.
Hey,
I'm a fan from the UK.
I found the ultimate challenge for the written no water champion,
master of accents previously a live episode.
You listened to someone from my home,
city of Liverpool thought they were Scottish.
Uh,
however these two brothers make that guy sound like the queen and just for the
record,
their accents are abnormally strong.
They sounded ridiculous.
Even to me add to that,
they also sound like they'd been drinking.
Imagine it in comprehensible for anyone outside of Liverpool.
So know that they in no way reflect all of us,
but that's what made me laugh a much love Danny.
So let's even see,
um,
I have the advantage of having the transcript with me.
So it's like,
okay,
well let's see,
cause I'll,
I'll just throw in the towel.
I don't know what the fuck these guys are saying.
Let's see if,
uh,
if you can get what these,
the first two lines are tweets.
So in other words,
the line that the first guy says and then the reply back.
Okay,
let's see what if you can get it.
Okay.
You got all
these islands at all and got to be fire dog around.
Yeah,
that is why I actually seeing it in front of me.
I'm like,
wow,
but no on Joe.
Do you know what they're saying?
I have an idea.
You have an idea.
This is just always the case.
Anyone from it sucks that there's a music bed because it'd be better without it.
They're talking about football.
That's true.
Football.
I think he was saying something about his playing and so I'm pretty sure it's
what's going on or if it's not that I'm talking to there.
How about a footballer?
Okay,
you're pretty close.
Okay.
I mean you're,
you're,
you're definitely in the right,
the right field.
You have a guest,
Jeanne.
Um,
he's talking shit to him.
He's like,
you're not shit.
And it's a either about,
he can,
maybe he can't drink enough.
He's a pussy with drinking or something like that.
Actually.
Your both your ideas together.
Football,
he's saying that his team?
I believe so.
The first guy says,
so how do you reckon we're going to get on side is the first thing you said and
then the reply is obviously use aren't going to win.
We're going to beat us or draw and get a replay at our ground.
Never,
whatever.
Now you know,
now that you know,
you'll hear it all.
[inaudible]
wow.
Yeah.
No,
that's fucking amazing.
I still don't hear it actually.
Once I'm having to really struggle and then the next,
here's the next uh,
mumbling too,
so it off.
If we don't have lost game too,
it's also making a tea get,
uh,
if I'm,
if I'm using the sink in my house and Brett talks to me,
I'm like,
oh,
I have no idea what you said.
If you could be right next to me,
sing song.
Oh,
here.
A guide in thing.
That's what this is.
Sync problem was a sync issue.
I had the same issue with our shower.
She'll be like,
Tom.
And I'm like,
yeah.
And then she's like,
nothing that I hear that just the water coming down issue.
If you're doing anything other than you're just listening.
I
don't hear you.
You don't hear me when you're doing anything other than listening.
When you're frying bacon,
you don't hear me.
When you're writing is a skill.
That right there.
Is it a skill that I developed my man as a skill I developed at home because my
mom talks constantly.
I have two younger sisters,
younger brother.
It's just a constant influx of eh,
eh,
Eh,
eh.
And so I learned to just shut it down.
They shut it down because it happened.
Was I developed a skill is in the same house home.
Yeah.
Growing up.
And then it's just,
I can't break it.
Yeah.
The one that I can't break and I don't even try to do this,
but I swear to you it is a fail proof is that if I'm reading something,
I don't hear anything.
I don't hear a thing.
Sometimes I'm that way.
I'll be reading it and she'll be like,
so,
and I'm like,
so what?
She goes,
did you hear anything I just said?
And I'm like,
no,
you can't do more than one thing at a time.
I mean,
really,
if you're reading,
you should not be able to hear anything.
Right.
If you're actually come comprehending what you're reading in Spanish,
really hear anything.
Yeah.
Um,
well this,
this accident though is really crazy.
Grandma Shannon.
No.
Yeah.
That might be the,
I mean I think this guy's right.
This might be the craziest one that I've,
this one's really right,
man.
He didn't park the bushy play.
Can I for four takes off
user salad and might use it just one Noel called cause you do it.
I'm Phil.
You're just celebrating.
Might cause he just won the World Cup.
You're celebrating like you won the World Cup Cup.
You're gay for play.
I saw you gave play.
You want to get on there and you gave the play and you were a at Ogle.
You want to just suck is on me now.
I'm a gay for playboy.
Gay for play and you gave her plan.
You want to do suck.
He's on me.
You're a big boy.
Big Puff.
Yup.
That's it.
And our families a blue or my older brother,
he was a rather new sorts of got older.
Me and Sam.
Yeah.
It's taught me on the Claudi path while they are always to the way I make my own
decisions on let you on with
yum,
yum.
That's all I hear it all man.
I make my own decisions.
I'm on the glide path.
So now they're,
now they're speaking.
They were doing,
they were acting the fool earlier.
They were,
that was t talk really storing them up.
I was pretty tall.
Yeah.
Fair enough.
Fair.
That isn't masterful master of accents.
No,
I'm very impressed.
It's wonderful.
That was bumbling too though.
Yeah.
A lot of mumble mumble rappers.
So it's got to go.
Are we going to go to the Oscars are coming up.
You've ever gotten?
No.
That's a fun question to ask someone though.
Have you ever been nominated?
No.
You would know that?
I think you would know.
I wouldn't,
I would probably lead with that.
I'd walk in the room.
Hey,
just so you know,
um,
I've been out here for an Oscar so just,
you know,
watch your tone.
I thought that was why we booked you cause I'm up for an arm right now.
I thought so.
Well I'm not,
I was in a movie that was nominated in the loop.
I got nominated for best adapted screenplay.
When,
when the nomination happens you get phone calls.
No,
cause I was an actor.
I know,
but still did they go like,
hey people start,
this was the first thing I ever did.
So no,
it was like just a,
that was just a,
there's just no,
no,
I don't get any phone calls for that cause there's a screenplay thing.
It wasn't like a,
you know,
I don't think anyone was Oscar's are screwing up by like really pushing
diversity.
I think the Oscars are,
have always just been pale 100%.
It doesn't make any sense.
Anyone he gets angry about Oscar nominations or wins is forgetting that none of
it makes any sense at all.
Like no one ever won an Oscar for the thing that they won an Oscar for.
What do you mean you win an Oscar for like a movie you did 10 years ago,
but they couldn't give it to you though.
Cause I had to give it to someone who needed an Oscar who from movie they did 10
years ago.
Oh right,
right.
Once in a while you get an Oscar nom thing.
It's just,
it's all just,
it's all payola too.
They put so much studios,
put so much money in trauma voting Oscar votes.
It's,
it's insane.
They put a push that shit like,
oh my God,
Millie system is rigged.
I put so much money into it and it's all just,
yeah,
cause it's all,
it's all like a cool contest.
Like who are you going to vote for?
Because who,
who does the academy want to feel like supporting at this time?
So the academy looks good.
Oh yes.
We gave it to them because we are obviously,
do you see how you see how we voted for them?
Cause we,
we like this.
We like this.
Cool.
We're cool.
We like these young Biz bumble core director.
We're,
we're supporting them even though it's not a comedy at all.
But yeah,
it's all,
it's all that.
I mean I still obviously wonderful if you get one,
I suppose.
And it's,
it's,
it's great and it's a real thing.
But at the same time,
this,
there's so many people who haven't been nominated for Oscars who deserve them
hands just 10 times over.
Any other people in their same category.
There's just not,
because maybe they're not sexy enough or,
well,
speaking of sexy,
do you feel like,
are you,
uh,
in,
you know,
in on these,
um,
the push to make the award shows genderless?
You know,
I don't know.
That seems kind of weird to me.
Ellison,
there'd be so many less awards.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I mean it's Kinda like a thing where if you do that then it doesn't,
it doesn't make any sense.
I just,
it seems like a pro,
you're creating a new problem that doesn't really exist.
That's enough.
There's not a,
there's not a problem there.
Is there a problem?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I didn't see all this stuff you have up there.
I don't even know that it was the thing right now.
Oh,
it's a thing.
Did you know and Canada Trudeau change their national anthem to be non gender
specific so they,
what did they use?
Non Binary.
It was something about there's a line in there like the boys are Blah Blah Blah
and they changed it to be gender neutral.
There's not like a historical reference to the boys who had like bed nets and
stuff probably.
Yeah.
Who died actually boys that did die.
Man.
I see that.
The,
what's the point of that?
What do you get here?
Oh No,
here it is.
Oh Canada.
Our home and native land.
True Patriot love in all thy sons command.
So they change it from in all thy sons command to in all of us command.
So I don't know there was that really bothering people.
I think it's bothering people more that he just went ahead and changed it.
That seems to be the,
the dilemma here.
Like,
hey dude,
we didn't nobody authorize that.
Like you can't just change our national anthem.
I think that's the general three Trudeau though.
It's very true.
Drove Trudeau brand.
Yeah.
It's on Trudeau about this gene.
Have you seen this go?
Oh,
I always like a good spark video.
that's really pretty.
I didn't see,
I knew that was going to happen,
but then you're like,
maybe it won't.
Maybe it won't work.
There you go.
So it's nice to see it.
Yeah.
A little nug.
Yeah,
I remember that part of Jackass Three d Dave England.
You seen this Jackass Three d?
I don't think so.
Off The three D.
I don't know if you got to see it.
They're so funny.
I love those dudes and we must see that one.
I feel like I'm,
I love them so much.
I love the show.
I saw it.
I think two films and we'll do three d is the one for me.
Okay.
That's the last one though.
Yeah,
there's a great,
is a great uh,
Poopoo one there.
I can,
I think about it,
um,
at least once a week.
Wow.
Really so satisfying.
Yeah,
it's truly amazing.
If he liked those,
you got to see my new movie coming out.
Do you,
do you have any movie coming out?
Yeah,
it comes out June 1st.
What is this?
It's called action point.
Action points,
but Action Park in New Jersey in,
but the old,
the old amusement park in New Jersey now he's like super dangerous.
Wasn't like the late seventies.
It was like a place where kind of like a drunks ran the rides.
It was a six people died.
Well,
it was open,
but having the best time in their lives like died like,
dude,
you should do that.
Oh really?
Okay.
Uh,
and so it was like a notoriously very fun kind of like working class place to
go,
but like real danger.
Yeah.
It's kind of like in Hungary,
the Communists built an amusement park there and I went in the nineties like
right as communism fell and it was truly terrifying.
Like the roller of safety restrictions.
Zero.
There was no seatbelt on the roller coaster,
not the trailer.
This is something wrong.
This is some,
some Chinese shit here,
man.
This is like some weird,
you know what I mean?
Some weird like Chinese,
like that's not it.
No,
it's not.
The trailer is not out yet.
I'll probably be out next month,
I think.
Interesting.
I don't know what,
how much trailers lead movies these days,
but it comes out in June.
It's Johnny Knoxville.
That's why I brought it.
Oh yeah.
It's not the comedy.
Yeah,
it's an action comedy.
It's Knoxville and Pontius.
They're like the two main people that I put like Knoxville's like lackey who's
like a great engineer.
Yeah,
it was fun.
We shot in South Africa for like three months,
man.
Oh Wow.
So it was a pretty uh,
why did you guys shoot there?
Because they shoot there cause they can basically get stuff for a quarter of the
price.
Cause we have like 300 extras every day.
They have this massive amounts but they had to build from scratch and amusement
park and this is a,
I'm supposed to be Jersey.
Yes.
Supposed to be,
well that's the thing.
They had to change it because South Africa is like southern California 10 years
ago,
record drought.
So they couldn't make it look green enough to be New Jersey so they made it.
They just basically everything is the same from action.
It's the story of Action Park but just changed to be a fictitious,
I could take space in California.
Wow.
Yeah.
Nice.
Speaking of some Chinese shit,
you know Chinese New Year,
it was two days ago.
Yeah.
You're the dog man.
Good.
This is a good year.
Basketball and the NBA is extremely popular in China,
but you just say basketball is extremely popular and then talk about something
else as well is,
was true of popular sport.
Okay.
So
yeah.
So anyways,
uh,
just as like a little promos,
nothing new.
They had a bunch of NBA players to a end,
like former players say like happy Chinese New Year on a promo tour.
Oh dear.
There's
a controversy right now.
This guy has apologized for and here's the amazing thing.
They released it this way.
First of all,
I'm just gonna play it for you and you tell me,
um,
you know what you think.
Okay.
So this is like just going through it.
These guys are just doing like,
oh,
happy new year.
Happy New Year and it'll,
you'll,
you'll see.
Okay.
Yup.
[inaudible]
happy new year and go Jess.
I just wanted to wish all of China and very happy Chinese New Year.
That was it.
What,
what happened?
What's offensive?
You're gonna see it again?
Yeah.
This is like,
I'm not sure I,
it's this guy right here.
No Way.
Yeah.
That he's had to issue like mold guy though.
He did the best job.
Okay.
Yeah,
me too.
I do the best job.
That was nice.
I get that last guy
fans in China.
I'm very happy with Chinese.
Oh,
that's I know
why?
Because he's inferring that only Chinese people in China celebrate.
You still missed it.
You said chant?
No,
he's,
do you see a word I didn't hear?
Yeah.
What'd he say?
He said Chink.
No,
he didn't say it.
He didn't say that.
He did.
I thought that it was him saying a different word.
It was one of those like,
oh,
Lee,
like a liaison or something.
They weren't goes between them.
He said it and then you could see all the,
like he basically restarted,
but they edit it together.
Okay.
Let's say one more time.
This is true.
It is true.
This is,
yes.
The jazz
bands and China.
Yeah.
Right in there.
He said the MBA,
Chink Fan.
The edit comes afterwards here.
See how they're doing?
Like a little transition.
Oh,
Chinese new year.
When you said the NBA Chink fans,
right?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
But it was like,
I don't think he's,
he actually was running back,
hey,
you fucking chinks.
Happy New Year.
I think you know,
sometimes your brain just morphs a word out that was not,
you didn't want to see,
I don't think he's trying to say it,
but he actually says it.
I got a question.
Yeah,
why wouldn't they edit that out if they edit it at all?
That that was one of the things that now later on they edit it out.
I don't think he said Chink.
What do you think he said?
I think he said China and the edit made it seem like he said that.
No,
because the edit happens afterwards.
He says no it one more time.
Yeah.
I swear to God says Nba Change Pants and then had it happened,
he goes like NBA Cheat Mba.
He like restarts.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because I think because he restarts cause he's like,
I'm not,
I think the word escaped his mouth,
his mouth and his mouse.
But I think that the,
he then tries to reset.
I don't think he's trying to say with the intent of saying like
a pejorative word,
but I think the actual five letters,
whatever just popped out of his mouth and then he just
didn't hear a k simple as that.
I know.
I'm not here.
Okay.
I heard a hard chunk.
You gotta listen,
I'm going to close my eyes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Just a little leery to go jazz
fans in China.
See,
I thought he said NBA Champ.
No.
Well,
the first time I saw it I was like,
oh,
I didn't said this is chat in here.
Check the first time either.
But then,
well,
this guys,
he said,
who is this guy?
He's a dumb ass dumb ass.
He's,
I know he's,
he's been doing apology after a poem.
How dumb.
It's like of all the people to piss off China.
I know.
And you know,
I'd actually forgotten the word Chink.
I don't even think of it anymore.
It's an old one.
Such an old school that way.
Now remember that word?
Yeah,
I was tongue tied.
Jeez.
Oh boy.
Why would they air it?
That's the silly.
Was it live or something?
Couldn't,
they have controlled that?
He says,
I just saw the video being circulated of me.
I was tongue tied as the word purportedly said is not in my vocabulary.
I'm disappointed and he would think I would use that word.
I love and respect our friends in China.
Then he did a second thing where he went further to all our NBA fans in China.
Sincerely apologize.
Anyone I have offended.
I was glad to do.
I was in Tennessee,
NBA,
Chinese fans.
I think that's what happened.
Cause I think this guy,
yeah,
he had to run away and he said as we record it and no one in the room,
not the NBA pro PR team.
Nobody heard the word that was important to say.
Anyways.
He's like doing,
you know,
apology after a pilot.
Oh Geez.
Um,
I'm saying he didn't say it.
You really still don't think you said it.
I don't think he said it.
Why would you say that?
But he said it.
But why would you,
it's like such a,
such a bad thing to say,
but I mean there's audio of it.
You can hear him right,
but isn't one of those things where if you are looking for it,
you'll find it.
Cause we don't want you to punch.
And it sounded like he just said NBA,
China,
they're in pain about without watching it.
Close your eyes.
Okay.
But now I know,
I'm just looking for that
China.
Yeah,
I wouldn't,
yeah,
I sound fans and we aid ching.
I'm saying that the,
I don't think the intent is there of,
of right insulting,
but I still think that that word came out of,
I don't mean,
I'm not saying you guys should be roasting.
Where did he grow up?
You think he grew up in Chinatown
here also the cadence to,
you know,
NBA,
Nba.
I want to thank all the NBA champ fans.
Yeah.
Ho knows.
Wait,
are you saying though that the word is still not the word coming out of his
mouth?
I just feel like it's something where,
uh,
it wasn't,
it's gotta be,
it's not malicious.
I say it's not malicious.
I don't fuck you on Chinese may.
Oh,
it's like a second.
I'm Chinese meal,
you're saying?
Yes.
Yeah.
Succulent Chinese meal.
Um,
I do love a second,
like Chinese meal who doesn't enjoy it?
He seems awfully young to throw out chink.
You know what I'm saying?
It does feel like an old time.
It's a grandpa word.
Yeah.
Like it's,
it's such an old colored or something,
you know,
it's not really,
you watch that Vietnam War documentary.
The Kim Burns one.
No,
there's so many words I say all the time that I'm like,
oh,
can't say that anymore.
Really?
Like dink,
dink.
Dink is a racial slur.
Evidently.
I mean,
I still keep saying it because Dank to me means stupid.
Like,
oh,
look at that.
Dinker trailing.
I think what's a dank?
It's a,
I guess it's a,
it's like a very specific word for Japanese,
I think in the real world war two or something like that.
It's like super specific.
It's,
yeah,
yeah.
That's an Asian person saying that.
I believe it.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
That's not me saying that.
Yeah,
it's fine.
Because talking about Johnny Pemberton said Ching Chong,
Ching Chong on the spot.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
Without them.
Ally,
she's on and make up.
What a bitch where.
I'm still cute to say.
Get the fuck up Outta here.
I'm,
I live a little bit more chicken,
Tom.
We don't get me fucked up bitch.
I'm still hurting.
She and we'll fuck.
Go Away.
Stop.
Okay.
You want to fuck with my money?
You want to fuck with my mind?
Who was that?
That's that Asian lady.
Damn,
that sounds like a like a weird hood girl from,
no,
she's in that Vietnam documentary.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
okay.
I met,
I didn't finish it.
Actually.
I only got to number 10 so it was probably the last part I was,
boy,
he was waiting.
So wait,
so dink is this racial slur?
It's like a really subtle one that no one knows,
but it's like a one that they would use.
Soldiers would say that.
How would you use it?
I say it like stupid.
Like,
Oh man,
look at that Dank.
He's trying to put it fit that bag and the overhead.
What a Dang Degas or something.
It sounds like a stump.
A stupid thing,
right?
Sounds like dingus or like flathead cost on the flat hat.
They're an idiot.
Oh,
that flathead.
And that's a racial slur.
I don't think flathead is now flat heads like an old that's like from the 18
hundreds I think flat face though is the racial faces.
Yeah.
But I might've just said flat face just now.
With that.
I don't wish to listen to audio.
Play it back.
Why don't you fucking wasted attorneys a happy new year and see what happens.
You know what?
I thought it was going to be for real,
cause I had a Chinese neighbor,
this lady named Jenny and she would always bring us stuff for Chinese New Year.
Right.
Happy for tennis,
Delia.
She'd always come over and say,
that
makes sense.
Okay.
That's what Jenny would say.
I hit her on the podcast years ago.
It was like the best podcasts ever recorded because she like would just ramble
on and on about stuff about Chinese new year and there's always things you can't
say.
You can't say anything.
I think the number four,
we never say four.
It's like extremely bad luck because if it's a square,
it's something,
it's really absurd.
Look man,
big time on luck.
And if you do something that is unlucky on Chinese new year,
it's like a curse.
If you do that to someone else,
you can basically curse them.
And she told me this and I thought this guy has said like,
um,
wishing you for more.
Like he said,
oh,
he said for,
he said the number four.
That's,
that's why I thought it was going to be like some weird thing.
Like what,
what's wrong with,
I can't say the number four.
I remember
learning that in Vegas basically.
Even the ones that don't appear to have any type of Asian influence or theme
casinos,
right.
Are All designed with Asian guests in mind.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Such a huge part of the gambling airfare.
And so it's like,
there was even,
MGM did a crazy thing,
uh,
like 10 years ago where they had an entrance that was,
I dunno if it was like a lion's mouth or something like that and a bunch of
Asians were like,
this wouldn't go in there.
Like,
yeah,
they didn't like it and so they were like Tara Nasha down tomorrow.
Like they yeah,
they did it immediately.
They,
they adhere to whatever that you know,
part of the world wants because they're big part of,
of gambling on a number eight.
They're like eight,
eight,
eight everyone the license plate,
that's the most desirable one.
Eight.
Lucky.
Yeah,
I think fours.
I'm pretty sure fours I'm lucky to have.
Okay,
so let,
yeah,
to have an uneven number of dogs.
Yeah.
I remember I did a Chinese guy just so you know.
Had his sister had three dogs cause two or four is unlucky.
Wow.
There you go.
Three dogs.
I think some of it comes from the word.
If a word sounds like another word.
Hmm.
It's,
it's that.
It's that arbitrary.
Who knows?
Bros got a vibration test.
Yeah.
This camera's silly.
It does its own thing.
Why do you,
why do you have it?
Oh,
why did we do anything?
We do anything.
Why don't we have,
have you done movies,
man,
coach Breaux coverage coverage,
it's different setup.
Okay.
Yeah.
You got Company and move.
Those are all the words I know.
I love a company move man.
Company and move.
Oh,
did the company move?
Oh God.
Okay.
Well we have base camp set up here.
We're going to push your call.
Actually we've got,
we've got forced calls.
Check the prelim audio Martini Shot Martini.
Oh,
is that the last one or second to last?
Um,
Wolf.
Okay.
Uh,
what does it MIT out sound?
Am I in my mls?
Right.
Mls middots sound without sound.
You know what that's from?
Meats is with a German,
right?
So it's because the German guy,
uh,
was the first guy that said it.
So they,
they have this expression is named mls,
those or movies saying modern led business.
Can you play that video?
We watched it before Johnny came.
Uh,
that kid,
the in the center of the city in the center of the city.
He let out a nice sound.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I remember thinking about it and I want to see it again.
And then,
um,
we also have to have him a guest.
Oh my God,
I can't wait.
[inaudible] the audience is going to be folks,
those guys,
it's coming.
Yes.
Um,
how I know did it done?
I love this because I feel like it's somewhere like in Brussels or something.
Somewhere like that.
Elgin.
Yeah.
That's incredible.
Where is this looks like as Europe somewhere.
And did you see,
did you see her jump?
No,
I miss jump.
Watch her.
Which one?
I wanted short.
Jack.
How long game?
Right here.
Are you looking at it?
Yeah.
That's amazing.
That's like boogers and revenge of the nerds.
Yeah.
So incredible.
Have you seen those homemade ship horns?
The people make shit porn.
The ship,
uh,
fall quarter and I saw one this morning.
That's the greatest thing I've ever seen.
Some guy in the back of his backyard in Kansas makes this horn at a PVC pipe and
an air compressor.
That sounds like a fucking cruise ship.
Just as docking really unbelievably loud.
Just like,
and it's,
you can tell this is loud as shit to imagine doing that in your apartment
complex.
Oh my God,
that's so cool.
It's so funny.
I think he does more.
That's a talent that is a real skill.
You see the girls run away.
That's going to be a match with a certain type of disease as well for bacterial
infection.
Might need to see your dad.
Um,
so fiber,
we all know a kid that could do that.
These girls get so scared of high school and they decided to run the other way.
This is the kind of guy,
like in the 16th century,
he would be a warlord.
Yeah.
Like you would just run into a village and do that.
Like,
oh,
we are scared of him.
Yeah.
Was it coming?
The king would either kill him or bring them around,
bring them around.
I want to see him do it again.
Bring in the man.
It's like a dying goats or something like a giant.
He goes,
okay.
The most popular guy in high school for sure.
Yeah.
There's always the guy that can do this early in life.
You discover these talents early.
I knew a guy used to be to suck in air to his ass and just fart.
Sure.
Unlimited.
I knew a girl that could queef on command.
Uh,
I knew I kid like kid burp like that.
I had a roommate that could suck air through his ass and Fart.
Sure.
And you know,
who did it used to do burps?
Burps are really big like that were Brian and Jeanette.
Really?
Oh Jeanette.
Definitely.
Really?
She's been on the show,
but the brain deep verb,
when there's a woman that can do it,
she's exceptional.
Yeah.
There was a girl in my high school that could do it.
Yeah,
she could do the alphabet.
It was pretty amazing.
Right.
The opposite.
I have,
I [inaudible] sound like a little lizard just died.
It's like they're terrible.
This sound like a,
like the crypt keeper or something like that and be like Gollum.
They're just,
they're really gross.
I hate them.
I'll do it.
I'll forget.
I have that burp and I'll do it around like a,
like a friend I'm comfortable with and I'm like,
are you okay?
And it sounds,
it sounds bad.
[inaudible] guys.
I don't have a man of video in a while,
but I'm to make it out to you because this year I've come up with something
called the super and super purpose where I saw all in a lot of air.
I wait till it sinks down into my stomach and then I saw the more air because it
makes her up instead of just barfing up.
Right.
Oh,
right away.
So give me a little bit,
be patient.
It's really painful to,
so it's hard to watch her federal and load it up.
Is that what she's wearing?
Her prom dress.
Nice.
Yeah.
Here we go.
I hate the buildup to it.
Yeah,
it was loud.
I feel like really good.
No,
that's really good.
All right.
She could rival the guy.
What about the king?
I didn't realize that.
He's got a corner right here it is.
Yeah.
Two liter.
This is king ass.
Repor Jun.
Yeah.
His perhaps aren't as good as,
as far as,
as far as our,
that's where his talent is.
Yeah.
I'm from Brooklyn.
I don't think he's just,
God Damn God damn.
He's got food on his shirt.
The animal that's by design though,
right?
Yeah.
Mean he stopped himself,
but he really goes really crazy.
You see a professional eater?
Yeah,
a lot.
And then a foreign fighter.
I watched a guy once eat five chipotle burritos and five minutes.
Wow.
Like in the state of nature.
And it was almost one of these guys,
one of these youtube guys.
No.
Like a power eater gotta be sick immediately after that.
Wow.
I've in five minutes.
Yeah.
It was something where it doesn't seem,
because they're so dense.
Right.
Does it seem humanly possible?
But I guess that's,
that's why we train.
That's why it's true actually true Kobayashi.
Those hearts are getting guys,
they do train.
You gotta stretch it,
stretch your stomach.
One of the competitive food ears and I didn't realize,
I was like,
Oh man,
how does that stuff pass through?
You think it was like,
oh no,
we could all puke it up.
And I'm like,
what a waste.
So just making it a dog food or something.
I do something with it.
Right.
They should do that.
They should actually vomit up all that stuff and make like a certain type of dog
food or horse food or something.
Yeah.
My dog would eat that.
He did a second bit.
Oh,
well we'll get vomit.
I'm in
food.
Yes.
Oh,
thank you daddy
food.
They love anything.
My dog drank half a drink,
10 ounces of salmon oil.
One night we came home,
I left the salmon oil,
buy her food on the floor thinking,
oh,
just because we put this in their food,
it doesn't mean that she's going to think it's your food.
No,
of course not.
She tore it open.
The carpets ruined the house,
smells like a fucking fish restaurant.
She vomited multiple times in eight to vomit again and she was,
she was sick for 48 hours.
It was like we thought she was going to fucking die from drinking all the salmon
post to put two pumps in their food and she had like the most,
the entire bottle of it.
And she kept,
even,
even after,
like even after we got home and we took care of everything and gave her charcoal
pills,
she's still a,
I think she vomited up and ate some more of it.
Why do they eat the Barf?
That's the worst smell.
Good.
It's like Jesus,
right?
Fifo got into some toms the other day,
but he didn't puke.
Puke can be like,
that looks good.
I know.
It's the worst I would,
I would eat,
I would do if I was a dog at 8:00 PM I would not eat pig.
What if it was like you a bunch?
I don't.
Oh,
she's got a real aversion to puking.
Yeah.
I have a kind of a phobia.
Wait,
we almost,
I almost fucking forgot again.
Okay.
So she's got big all hangers on it,
a huge tits.
And I'm pregnant too,
that a lot of speculation.
I've got big tits even before I got pregnant.
I've always had big tits,
always has fucking grading or fifth grade and she's nice.
Always had big tits.
So a few weeks ago she's like,
God,
you know what I mean?
She's always like,
my back hurts,
these tastes are so big.
I got to slice these things off.
And I don't say that I just slice them off,
but they're getting bigger with some off pregnancy.
I want to get a reduction down yet.
So they're getting big with pregnancy and then she goes,
how much you think my tits way.
So I'm sitting down and she's standing up and I reached my hand up and I was
like,
I dunno,
like 15 pounds or something.
It's a huge,
yeah.
And so we start talking about on the show and then we talk about how about like
how can we actually get these things legit weighed.
So people start sending in ideas and then one of them was doing meat scales.
Yeah.
Like a good idea.
That was like,
that makes sense.
Yeah,
that'd be a good one.
We also thought that actually we always,
we as without the local whole foods would be into it.
You know the sponsorship.
Sure.
Just go in there,
drop that big old slop or on that food scale and see what it was.
Yeah.
But then we realized,
you know,
maybe they won't.
So we ordered a food scale and we brought it to the we,
we,
we brought out the hangars and we put the milk flaps on the foods and the studio
before you came today.
Now it's an inexact science.
Of course.
Obviously there's a margin of error here because of what about my force without
my pushing down.
And you know,
it's,
it's an imperfect science.
So I think we got kind of an estimate here on what
these hangers way Johnny,
take a look.
What do you think is your wife?
Big chested or something,
but she's not pregnant.
What size?
So he knows what he's looking at.
Okay.
So before I was pregnant,
they were quadruple ds.
Now they're even beggars that exponential with the DIY thing.
Cause it's like how many days until you get to the e four.
So it goes four days and then the next size up is an e.
Okay.
So you're on,
you're on the cusp of a d no,
girl,
I'm sorry.
I'm on the cusp of Drupal now.
Now I am an as I am and here he adjacent quadrupled.
Okay,
got it.
Yeah.
The triple DSL.
Ut those are big.
Okay.
So how much does that weigh?
What,
what'd you say?
I'm telling you.
We're talking about one GAM.
One,
one man.
Okay.
We'll talk about a single one.
Not the,
not collective.
Okay.
Rob.
Rob,
Jesus Christ.
I'm going to guess.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
hugs.
How much do I have to narrow it down to there's two breasts and we weighed them
both separately.
I think you can guess.
You don't have to be like the left one.
Is this the right one?
Is that you just have to guess one number.
Cumulus and,
Oh,
you wanted him to guess.
I mean like it,
it's very difficult to gauge what each one individually,
what's it,
the cumulative.
What do you,
what do you think both of these honkers together,
what am I carrying on my chest?
What is,
what was your initial gas before?
Like way back was your initial guests.
Initial guests was like 15 pounds,
15 pounds each.
Well,
I did think that,
I did think that too high.
That's not even possible.
I don't know.
But I thought gravity,
we just pull me to the floor.
I know.
I'm,
I say I'm going to say a seven pounds co collective,
but no one each seven.
Seven.
Wow.
No,
no,
I,
it's hard.
It's so hard because my dog is so big.
It's like a thing where,
you know,
I think about animal weight,
right?
And I'm so strong that like I pick up my heavy dog and it's like,
um,
I will,
I'm going to have to say five and a half as the cumulative Cayman's know as
each,
each breast is five and a half.
Oh Wow.
Okay.
All right.
That's my final answer.
The final answer.
And you,
well,
I mean,
I know,
oh that's right.
But before you said about 15 and I guessed about it feels about 10 to 15 so
your,
your final answer is five and a half each.
Each meaning 11 total.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well here we go.
You ready to
get ready for it?
The Deli scale
milkers we call crackers.
We have start with the righty.
The lesser.
So now as is common with most women,
my boobs are not perfectly symmetrical.
One is bigger than the,
is a little bit of of a breast meat.
Let me see.
Okay.
I can get it out.
Nevermind.
I could get it out.
Please get it out.
Yeah,
go on.
These people seeing my sloppers the funky dunkers you mean fuck it.
Younger ready?
My favorite new when you were younger.
Okay.
That is my right breast.
That is 2.16 pounds.
Yeah.
I totally overshot.
Didn't way [inaudible] feels like five.
Like and again,
we might not be doing it correctly.
Well,
here's the thing is that the skill,
you know,
fluctuated,
but I'm kind of just rounding,
um,
I feel as though it's,
it's an,
it's an accurate enough.
Did you,
uh,
did you have it where the breasts was a,
wasn't obviously,
it wasn't so high as to have it be,
you're below the scale.
You're not doing that,
which are also high enough to where I guess you know what it feels like for the
full [inaudible] was at chest level.
Like it was right there.
But it's also this thing,
it's like what?
Where does the breasts begin?
All right God,
I do what I wanted to do to do by the way.
Yeah.
I want to do it standing where the breasts is that where the countertop is,
let's say.
Right.
And you just go boom.
That's just how did you do it then we did it.
But a CD you gotta stand cause you get,
it's like of all things you got to stand it.
But listen,
here's the thing,
what's the difference between,
it's not going to fluctuate between two and five pounds.
If I'm sitting or standing,
I feel as though this is an accurate approximation.
Let's just try it again.
So here,
that was the rest of the system.
This is righty.
Okay.
And then here is this battle and this is the big three point big fluctuation.
One seven.
So one is a full pounder,
which is actually true because this one is an entire cup size larger.
Yeah,
always my whole life.
So I've had to get a cup size smaller to go for both of you guys want to tell
you I'm not the most romantic guy or anything,
but you got a huge tits that ain't no shit.
Expand interrupting.
And there's a medical doctor out there that will in the Los Angeles area that
will weigh my breasts more accurately if you want.
Do you want to go see a medical doctor that listens to this?
And that's true.
That's true.
And he was like,
Yo,
well your tits for you.
Why now?
Like Trump's doctor,
that guy,
that guy is so awesome man.
You do anything.
Yeah.
Well I think this is a nice,
it's a roundabout also the grand total of those was like five point what it was
it five and change how points from it feels about right.
Yeah.
So if you're,
if you're per
mmm.
If your guests of the chemo native wait,
was the actual your guests of the each weight.
Yeah,
you would.
You'd have been spot on.
Yeah,
I guess I just don't know what breasts way.
I know and I,
and I really do want to try the standing method.
I just want to see if it changes your honor it let's do it tonight.
It's all because he,
I guess I forget that that type of tissue is not right.
Dance.
Well why?
Well yeah now it's getting full of milky and stuff to the milk ducts because of
the baby.
Yeah.
Milky.
He's on there all milky
way when they're going to be fully in gorged with Milliken.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Well now you can chart your progress.
I can like you can try your progress.
This might be some sort of breakthrough breast cancer research.
Actually.
That's a really good idea.
And keep a chart.
Yeah,
I like that.
You could have a chart on the wall.
Yeah.
Next to every song is wait your son's height.
You can put it next to it.
It's a really good idea when you were this tall.
My breasts weighed this much.
It's a really good point.
I think five is about right cause there's this video people sent us about
animals and how much the animal weighs and comparison to the breast.
And uh,
it seems about right cause my,
my ted sizes like two chickens.
That's what this video said.
I love chickens.
Yeah.
I need to,
chickens are great.
So there you go.
Big Mystery.
Big,
uh,
big reveal guys.
Um,
okay.
What do you look for gene?
I was looking for a song.
Oh,
an outro?
Yeah,
I found it.
That's a lot of weight to carry around.
I got to get these fuckers reduced.
Uh,
Johnny Pemberton and working people.
See you Amy.
Action points.
Yeah.
Action
Park.
When it comes out.
Action Point.
I always get confused.
I get come.
You were right.
I was wrong.
All right.
Ah,
you know,
Instagram,
Youtube.
I post a lot of videos on youtube.com/just my nipples.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And um,
Instagram,
I post videos on there.
It's just Johnny underscore Pemberton and I've got an album coming out on
Starburns audio.
And uh,
where's your recording?
Oh,
well it's actually a compilation of all the best prank phone calls.
I've done love prank phone calls.
I have some of them on my youtube channel,
but most of them are just going to be on the album.
It will be on,
it's going to be on a cassette.
They have a cassette club that's also going to be available digitally cause
obviously,
uh,
cassettes or cassettes.
So that's amazing.
So do you,
do you do calls regularly?
Yeah,
I've been doing them for a long time and I do mostly,
they're not prank phone calls.
They're more like a,
I called customer service places and um,
kind of engage with people in a way that I think they're not used to being
engaged with.
That's great.
I got to hear some of them.
Give me an idea of like what kind of,
just like I always pretend to be a guy named Kevin tip corn and I usually call
with like a legit complaint about something and it just sort of starts to get
really absurd and I ask a lot of personal questions like what you're having for
lunch.
And,
uh,
I just get really,
like there's one,
I basically just tried to get weird people out to the point where they are
trying to stop the call,
but I know that they can't,
I used to work in call centers.
I know how it works,
the politics of it.
So yeah,
I called like Aveda,
I'm complaining about these little ball like scrubbing balls inside the shampoo,
talking about how he look like lice and trying to get through to the girl starts
talking about her hair care and stuff.
And I have one cognitive uh,
calling the police,
asking them like weird questions about their phone system.
It's a strip club call with a guy.
I just went on about asking all these questions like country kind of a glove and
can I like kind of worse 20 to wear shorts and he just is indulging me for some
weird reason.
The constantly I called Halliburton,
somebody Halliburton talks about chem trails and all kinds of shit like that.
It's great man.
Yeah,
it's called,
uh,
um,
recorded for quality assurance.
Nice.
Great.
All right,
so look for it,
look for it a go.
See the movie action point actually?
Yeah.
June 1st and I'll be in New York,
uh,
March 1st through 12th students from shows.
Oh,
great.
Yes.
All right.
You'll tweet them or posting.
Yeah,
there'll be tweeted and posted and like real,
you know,
just totally done.
Yeah.
All right.
What don't you tell him you're going to be there.
Why don't you tell me?
Oh God,
I'm so tired of that.
Uh,
Jay,
Pepperdine,
you were great.
Thank you very much.
Thanks.
You guys are great.
And uh,
we'll see you guys next week.
Check you out by,
by,
by Jane.
My jeans near my son.
I'm your mom.
You're my son.
I'm your mom asked them,
will you ask,
ask,
ask them when you do update your mom.
Yes.
I would hear my son.
I'm your mom.
It's just like the gaze,
just like,
just like the gate.
I looked at her and she looked at me
because like the gate,
once my wife calls me,
mom,
you,
I mean,
both consenting adults
asked him,
when I asked him,
when you,
I looked at her and she looked at me and hear my son,
I'm your mom.
Just like the gate
the gate.
Ask them,
will you pass pass,
pass.
It's just like the gays.
Yeah.